Today we’re going to describe
the datapath and control logic
needed to execute
Beta instructions.
In an upcoming lab assignment,
we’ll ask you to build
a working implementation using
our standard cell library.
When you’re done, you’ll have
designed and debugged a 32-bit
reduced-instruction
set computer!
Not bad…
Before tackling a design task,
it’s useful to understand
the goals for the design.
Functionality, of
course; in our case
the correct execution of
instructions from the Beta ISA.
But there are other goals
we should think about.
An obvious goal is to
maximize performance,
as measured by the
number of instructions
executed per second.
This is usually
expressed in MIPS,
an acronym for “Millions of
Instructions Per Second”.
When the Intel 8080
was introduced in 1974,
it executed instructions at 0.29
MIPS or 290,000 instructions
per second as measured by
the Dhrystone benchmark.
Modern multi-core processors
are rated between 10,000
and 100,000 MIPS.
Another goal might be to
minimize the manufacturing
cost, which in integrated
circuit manufacturing
is proportional to the
size of the circuit.
Or we might want have the best
performance for a given price.
In our increasingly
mobile world,
the best performance per watt
might be an important goal.
One of the
interesting challenges
in computer
engineering is deciding
exactly how to balance
performance against cost
and power efficiency.
Clearly the designers
of the Apple Watch
have a different
set of design goals
then the designers of
high-end desktop computers.
The performance of a
processor is inversely
proportional to the length of
time it takes to run a program.
The shorter the execution time,
the higher the performance.
The execution time is
determined by three factors.
First, the number of
instructions in the program.
Second, the number of clock
cycles our sequential circuit
requires to execute a
particular instruction.
Complex instructions,
e.g., adding two values
from main memory, may
make a program shorter,
but may also require
many clock cycles
to perform the necessary
memory and datapath operations.
Third, the amount of time
needed for each clock cycle,
as determined by the propagation
delay of the digital logic
in the datapath.
So to increase
the performance we
could reduce the number of
instructions to be executed.
Or we can try to minimize the
number of clock cycles needed
on the average to
execute our instructions.
There’s obviously a bit of a
tradeoff between these first
two options:
more computation per
instruction usually
means it will take more time
to execute the instruction.
Or we can try to keep our
logic simple, minimizing
its propagation delay in the
hopes of having a short clock
period.
Today we’ll focus on an
implementation for the Beta ISA
that executes one instruction
every clock cycle.
The combinational paths in our
circuit will be fairly long,
but, as we learned in
Part 1 of the course,
this gives us the opportunity
to use pipelining to increase
our implementation’s throughput.
We’ll talk about the
implementation of a pipelined
processor in some
upcoming lectures.
Here’s a quick refresher
on the Beta ISA.
The Beta has thirty-two
32-bit registers
that hold values for
use by the datapath.
The first class of
ALU instructions,
which have 0b10 as the top
2 bits of the opcode field,
perform an operation on two
register operands (Ra and Rb),
storing the result back
into a specified destination
register (Rc).
There’s a 6-bit opcode field to
specify the operation and three
5-bit register fields to specify
the registers to use as source
and destination.
The second class of
ALU instructions,
which have 0b11 in the
top 2 bits of the opcode,
perform the same set of
operations where the second
operand is a constant in
the range -32768 to +32767.
The operations include
arithmetic operations,
comparisons, boolean
operations, and shifts.
In assembly language, we
use a “C” suffix added
to the mnemonics shown here
to indicate that the second
operand is a constant.
This second instruction
format is also
used by the instructions
that access memory and change
the normally sequential
execution order.
The use of just two
instruction formats
will make it very easy
to build the logic
responsible for translating
the encoded instructions
into the signals
needed to control
the operation of the datapath.
In fact, we’ll be able to use
many of the instruction bits
as-is!
We’ll build our
datapath incrementally,
starting with the logic
needed to perform the ALU
instructions, then add
additional logic to execute
the memory and
branch instructions.
Finally, we’ll need to add logic
to handle what happens when
an exception occurs and
execution has to be suspended
because the current instruction
cannot be executed correctly.
We’ll be using the digital logic
gates we learned about in Part
1 of the course.
In particular, we’ll need
multi-bit registers to hold
state information from one
instruction to the next.
Recall that these
memory elements
load new values at the rising
edge of the clock signal,
then store that value until
the next rising clock edge.
We’ll use a lot of multiplexers
in our design to select between
alternative values
in the datapath.
The actual computations
will be performed
by the arithmetic
and logic unit (ALU)
that we designed at
the end of Part 1.
It has logic to perform the
arithmetic, comparison, boolean
and shift operations listed
on the previous slide.
It takes in two 32-bit operands
and produces a 32-bit result.
And, finally, we’ll use several
different memory components
to implement register storage in
the datapath and also for main
memory, where instructions
and data are stored.
You might find it useful
to review the chapters
on combinational and sequential
logic in Part 1 of the course.
The Beta ISA specifies
thirty-two 32-bit registers
as part of the datapath.
These are shown as the magenta
rectangles in the diagram
below.
These are implemented as
load-enabled registers, which
have an EN signal that
controls when the register is
loaded with a new value.
If EN is 1, the register will
be loaded from the D input
at the next rising clock edge.
If EN is 0, the register is
reloaded with its current value
and hence its
value is unchanged.
It might seem easier to add
enabling logic to the clock
signal, but this is
almost never a good idea
since any glitches in that logic
might generate false edges that
would cause the register to load
a new value at the wrong time.
Always remember the
mantra: NO GATED CLOCKS!
There are multiplexers (shown
underneath the registers)
that let us select a value
from any of the 32 registers.
Since we need two operands
for the datapath logic,
there are two such multiplexers.
Their select inputs
(RA1 and RA2)
function as
addresses, determining
which register values will
be selected as operands.
And, finally, there’s a decoder
that determines which of the 32
register load enables will be
1 based on the 5-bit WA input.
For convenience, we’ll package
all this functionality up
into a single component
called a “register file”.
The register file
has two read ports,
which, given a
5-bit address input,
deliver the selected register
value on the read-data ports.
The two read ports
operate independently.
They can read from
different registers
or, if the addresses
are the same,
read from the same register.
The signals on the left
of the register file
include a 5-bit value (WA)
that selects a register
to be written with the specified
32-bit write data (WD).
If the write enable
signal (WE) is
1 at the rising edge of
the clock (CLK) signal,
the selected register will be
loaded with the supplied write
data.
Note that in the BETA ISA,
reading from register address
31 should always
produce a zero value.
The register file has internal
logic to ensure that happens.
Here’s a timing diagram
that shows the register file
in operation.
To read a value
from the register
file, supply a stable
address input (RA)
on one of read ports.
After the register
file’s propagation delay,
the value of the selected
register will appear
on the corresponding
read data port (RD).
[CLICK]
Not surprisingly,
the register file
write operation is
very similar to writing
an ordinary D-register.
The write address
(WA), write data (WD)
and write enable (WE) signals
must all be valid and stable
for some specified setup
time before the rising
edge of the clock.
And must remain stable and valid
for the specified hold time
after the rising clock edge.
If those timing
constraints are met,
the register file will
reliably update the value
of the selected register.
[CLICK]
When a register value is written
at the rising clock edge,
if that value is selected
by a read address,
the new data will appear
after the propagation delay
on the corresponding data port.
In other words,
the read data value
changes if either the read
address changes or the value
of the selected
register changes.
Can we read and write
the same register
in a single clock cycle?
Yes!
If the read address becomes
valid at the beginning
of the cycle, the old
value of the register
will be appear on the data
port for the rest of the cycle.
Then, the write occurs at the
*end* of the cycle and the new
register value will be available
in the next clock cycle.
Okay, that’s a brief run-though
of the components we’ll be
using.
Let’s get started on the design!